welcome everybody well before we get
going tonight I feel that it's very
important that I dress you all directly
as a journalist for 26 years now it is
my job to bring you news about others
rather than turning the focus on myself
but by now I'm sure that most of you
have heard the audiotape which became
national news and part of the
presidential race my name was mentioned
and unfortunately the release of it has
thrown me in the middle of the political
arena of which I didn't ask to be a part
I released a statement on Saturday and I
truly mean what I said there is no room
for objectification of women or anyone
for that matter not even in the locker
room the conversation has got to change
because everybody deserves respect no
matter the gender or setting and as a
mom I have to add that our kids
especially our young girls need to know
that their hard work their achievements
their intelligence their heart are most
important and those things will not go
unnoticed I also want to take this time
now to thank you the viewers who so
graciously open your homes Entertainment
Tonight every night I've been flooded
with your messages from around the world
and I so appreciate all of your kind
words I have been reading as many as I
can
and they are completely renewing my
faith that we all want a better and more
inclusive society so once again I thank
you all for your support
you